so what's the wildest thing you've ever
done for money that you can say on
television oh
we all have those moments
comedy that's a wow I guess do you
handle like hecklers or anything like
that well like especially when you first
started I haven't had some some good
moments yeah against the Heckler yeah do
you I kind of love even when someone at
a show like I'm singing they like did
this get loud they're excited maybe had
too much to drink I love playing with
those people right right and you gotta
like you know kind of feel the mouse see
if they're yeah like with you or against
you because sometimes I'm good
somebody's just like I love you yeah
I don't think I love you too but um and
some people Yeah just they want to be
part of the show and you gotta I don't
know they're not yeah it says Craig
Robinson it's your name Craig it might
be Craigslist
I heard that you
have a stand-up show last year oh oh
yeah yeah it was an active shooter
and uh yeah it was in a North Carolina
and there was a active shoot a guy came
in and uh
and she came he came in and he had a gun
and luckily it was between shows so they
just seated like one table and then he
came in and he said he waved at the
front of staff and some of the patrons
anybody's going to want to get shot you
know get out and then they got us to
safety does that scare you at all like
to get back in there no I don't I don't
I don't worry about it you know a
one-time thing and and he actually was
coming to see another show so I don't
think I was targeted but I I like I said
we were I felt more than safe being
there okay it was just the fact that
that he had arrived I love that you
don't let fear drive you that or keep
you from doing something wow yeah but
yeah I'm sure that night it was like
maybe I should change vocations
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
I'm going
[Music]